being there even a couple munich i saw
see my son called the miserable Keith
Odell the hottest alpaca
well it's morning here now in the
Austria Germany border at about half of
the people that were here last night
seemed to have been able to cross but
Hamid and our friends that we traveled
with here yesterday still in line yeah
it's Mozilla guy the guy who collection
they feel like shit but they're still
laughing if they wanted to relax a
little bit of spicy fun
I mean in general and if they don't they
might look at people who look healthy
and they look like they're you know well
dressed and we'll put together and they
say like well why why do they need to
come to Europe I know
we'll just has nothing to be to do with
war I mean were can destroy our our
houses okay but the world won't ever
destroy ours the war will not destroy
our good-looking okay I mean we still
good-looking guys I think so maybe
I hope that we're not making Germans
feel bad we're sorry for their but we're
trying to be polite you are trying to be
a good refugees with a good future and
as I told you before we are a good
educated people so why do you think some
Germans feel bad maybe cuz you know we
are a huge numbers we're gonna enter now
people are singing how relieved are you
right now that you're gonna enter
probably soon yeah
somehow I'm really not that relief but
once I would get to the borders I'll be
relieved I think it's like you won't
believe it until it happens yeah women
in Germany that's thing again the first
thing I will search for a really hot
bath oh the last time you took a bath or
shower
well like five days you know you don't
smell bata smell bad considering that
course because I'm using a lot of
perfume and you know this is which are
no deodorant judgments yeah yes
I'm the last of em what's up are you
happy or just English how do you feel I
feel a few I do freedom look at these
smiles
look at this smile Delano now now's the
time the thing exactly we're nothing
Germany but we're going there at least
we're moving at least you're moving
okay so we have to stop filming now
that's what the German police just told
us
we reach the other side looks like
there's a line still will it's a gay can
just get us here you can call me there
we'll catch up with you okay okay come
to Germany and then wherever we will be
there sounds like a plan oh yeah I think
so
that's it hey guys I'm in sigmaringen
now some of us supported and we went to
different cities but we okay I feel
happy now I've just paid my friend his
name is Lucifer and don't worry about
him is my brother that's the end of the
journey I think